much loved and incredibly popular
tributes are pouring in for 12 year old
ava white killed in liverpool last night
she lit up the room and she came in
because she was so kind and so caring
you have somewhere people will talk over
and be loud but she wasn't she was just
so sweet and that's how staff remember
and that's how all of staff have said
today she was quiet she was kind she was
caring and for this to happen to her
it's devastating
ava was killed just after christmas
lights were switched on here on church
street in the busy shopping district in
the heart of the city
today police confirmed four teenagers
have been arrested and are being
questioned at police stations across
liverpool
what we do know at this stage is that
ava was in liverpool city center with
some friends yesterday afternoon evening
that she was involved in an argument a
verbal argument which escalated to an
assault
we believe involving a knife
and that there were catastrophic
injuries and tragically she died
tributes lay close to where eva was
killed as the investigation into what
happened and why continues
sadia chowdhury sky news in liverpool